Along with displaying the genome sequence, shown
at the top of the genome browser image, the genome
browser also allows us to view various tracks
aligned with the genome sequence in the lower
portion of the browser image. A track is a visual
representation of a data set related to the genome
sequence above it. Tracks can show data from
diverse data sets, such as gene predictions mRNA
or RNA-Seq expression data, sequence similarity to
other organisms, and information about repeats and
variation associated with a certain region of
the genome. Depending on the researcher's goals,
it is often helpful to display only a subset of
the available evidence tracks. You can control the
display mode of each track through the drop-down
lists at the bottom of the genome browser page.
For example, the tracks that show sequence
similarity to other organisms and the gene models
from different gene predictors are available under
the Genes and Gene Prediction Tracks category.
Each track has up to five display modes.
For example, if we click on the drop-downlist for the Base Position track,
the first track under the Mapping and Sequencing Tracks category, we can change the display to one of the threedisplay modes available: hide, dense, or full.
In contrast, if we click on the drop down list for the
Gap track, we will see the five display modes that
are available: hide, dense, squish, pack and full. To
better understand how the display modes affect the
Genome Browser image, we will experiment with the
different display settings for the D. mel Proteins
track. Scroll down to the genes and gene prediction
tracks category, change the display mode for the
D. mel Proteins track to "hide," and then click on therefresh button. "Hide" means this particular trackwill not be shown at all.
Now we will change thedisplay mode for the D. mel Proteins track to "dense" and then hit refresh. "Dense" means the selectedtrack is displayed with all features collapsed
into a single line, irrespective of whether there
are overlapping features. In this case, you can
see that all the features in the D. mel Proteins
track are shown in one line. This mode is useful
for reducing the amount of space used by a track when you don't need to access the individual items
or when you just want to get an overall view
of the distribution of the features along the
genomic region of interest. Let's now change the
display mode for the D. mel Proteins track to "full."
We see that there are many more features in the
D. mel Protein section of the Genome Browser image.
That is because the full display option shows
each annotation feature on a separate line. Because
this display mode may result in an overwhelming
number of items, it should only be used when you
are examining a small genomic region. To reduce the
height of the Genome Browser image, we can change
the display mode for the D. mel Proteins track to
"pack." In pack mode, the track is displayed with each
annotation feature shown separately and labeled,
but overlapping features are shown on separate
lines. Hence, this display mode offers a good
compromise between the dense and full display
modes. The final display mode, "squish," is similar
to pack mode, but each feature is shown at half
the height of the features in pack mode. This
allows the genome browser image to show more data
per inch of screen height. This display mode is
particularly useful for high density data tracks,
such as displaying all of the RNA-Seq reads
that have been mapped to a genomic region.